>> Speaker One: From the Library
of Congress, in Washington, D.C.
>> In our final talk before lunch,
Patrick Cronin and Thomas Neville,
organizers of THATClass,
will share a story
about their summer camp last year,
working with high school students
to research the 1968
Washington, D.C. riots.
Thomas, Patrick, please
take it away.
>> Thomas Neville: Honor to be here.
Thank you, very much.
>> Singer: Everybody ready.
[inaudible].
[ Singing ]
Oh, I feel all right, this morning.
Yeah.
[ Blues Guitar Music ]
[ Singing And Guitar Music ]
[ Singing ]
You ain't nothin' but a hound
dog, [inaudible] 'round my door.
You ain't nothin' but a hound dog.
>> Speaker Two: Can you tell me
what you [inaudible] to begin?
>> Student One: So, I'm into music.
And I'm just trying to figure
out, or just look at things,
how music like influences
the society, culture,
and just really anything
about music.
And I was told about a court
case on Elvis Presley copyright
on the song ''Hound Dog''.
Pretty sure a lot of
people know that.
And basically, it's actually
a version [inaudible]
African [inaudible].
An African American wrote
it and it was their song.
But kind of, Elvis kind
of made it his own.
>> Student Two: It's an interesting
change, since you know, usually,
[inaudible] library, you
only go into libraries.
As a student, I've really seen
archives before this [inaudible].
>> Speaker Two: What do you think
you're going to find in the file?
>> Student Three: I'm
not sure, right now.
But this guy, I'm still trying to
figure out what he got arrested for.
But yeah. I don't know, yet.
Hopefully, something interesting.
>> Speaker Two: What
did [inaudible]?
>> Student Four: The [inaudible]
Ferry Towers master plans from 1950.
>> Speaker Two: Okay.
And how did you come about
wanting to know about this?
>> Student Four: Well, ideas,
like have some projects
like [inaudible] housing.
So, I'm looking at housing designs
and like history throughout Atlanta.
And I'm also going to like look
how it's designed, because I want
to have a new design that
doesn't victimize the residents
that stay there.
>> Speaker Two: Okay.
>> Joel Walker: The internet,
you're just looking at,
you know, a digital copy.
And I just can't imagine
that kids get overly excited
about looking at a screen.
>> Student Two: It [inaudible]
provides a more interesting aspect
than if you're looking
just on a computer.
Since coming here, just
looking at it in person,
you really get the interesting feel.
I don't know how to describe it.
It's nicer, I guess.
>> Speaker Two: And physically,
in front of you, what is that?
>> Student One: Well, this is
what I was just told, a song disc.
I'm not sure exactly what this is.
But I know the one
before it, this is.
Because these are records.
And they're 45's.
So, 45 is a lot of speed.
And this is, this is right
here, is ''Hound Dog''.
>> Speaker Two: And how is
listening to music on this different
than listening to music
through that?
Or is it the same?
>> Speaker Three: It's not.
>> Student One: It's not the same.
Because well one, it's I don't know.
It's vert authentic.
That's the only thing I can say.
All the snap, crackle, and pops.
>> Joel Walker: The other thing
is not everything is going
to be on the internet.
You know, we've calculated that if
we scan 40,000 scans a month here,
we would be done in 1,300 years.
And so, not everything is
going to be on the internet.
And what is on the internet
has already been discovered.
Where when you have the box
experience, you may find something
that nobody else has found, before.
And that's actually more
common than people might think.
>> Speaker Two: Did
that happen, today?
>> Joel Walker: Yeah, exactly.
A young lady looked at
record group, it was RG31.
I don't remember the
name of the record group.
I had never been on
that record group.
Nathan had never been
on that record group.
Sarah [assumed spelling] had
never been on that record group.
And we have worked here
for a combined 22 years.
>> Student Four: I wanted
to look at the outside
and how you can't really
see when you're segregated,
how people that need
housing can't afford it.
But people that have
housing, they can.
I wanted to see how to bring
both of these people together.
And so, it doesn't victimize a
lower class than upper class.
>> Speaker Two: I think
I'm going to come back
and see what else you find, later.
Thank you, so much.
>> Student Four: You're welcome.
>> Patrick Cronin: We met
these students that morning.
Now, traditionally, when high school
students go to the National Archives
or to a special collections
area, they get a tour.
And they're lucky if
they see, maybe,
some prize collections
and then, they go home.
So, before lunch, this group got to
use the finding aids, themselves.
They got to consult personally
and privately with an archivist.
And they got to touch
neglected archival materials.
Then, in the afternoon,
they were ready
to let the archival materials
guide their research.
>> Thomas Neville: So, Patrick
and I started work with students
and archives about five years, ago.
We were both teaching history at
a nearby high school, together.
When we arrived, it was one of
these schools where, largely,
that engagement with
the past was restricted
to the traditional textbook
and testing curriculum.
And Patrick had come in with a lot
of project based learning
experience.
I've been dabbling with archives.
And we had been strategizing
on what might make a richer
experience for these students.
And what might they actually be
capable of if you empowered them
and put them in that position.
And the result was us
being the students first,
as you saw on the last slide.
And because the limitations
of a normal school,
we can't just hop up
and leave campus.
So, we went to the archives.
We went to another archive.
And we bundled what we could
and recreated what we could
of the archive in the
classroom, to get started.
We replaced a textbook unit
with local archival materials
that cover the same time, and we
felt addressed the same things
and challenged to the
American experience.
So, just a few things that you
can see in this time period.
Students merging technology and
primary documents in the classroom.
Working with experts
from the community.
This is local writer and
historian, John Muller.
We scaffold them up
to the experience,
and then we bring them
to the archives.
This is the National
Archives, just down the road.
And the first student that
got their research ID.
We had go into the finding
aids, work with the archivists.
Learn how to make a pole.
She put in her pole, and as the
students finished getting their
research cards, they came in
and they taught one
another how to do this.
And they left there, knowing how
to navigate that location in a way
that some other folks might have
said, ''Yeah, but that's sort
of above their pay
grade,'' so to speak.
Actually, when we arrived
on the research side,
they said student groups, they
[inaudible] on the other side.
And so, these students kind of came
in and broke the norm in that sense.
And we also interacted
with community members.
This is the legendary Reverend
O.J. [assumed spelling],
giving us a oral history
walking tour
of the alley that he grew up in.
Because this is one of the topics
that our students are researching.
And in addition to not just
interacting with the archives,
we had them thinking about how
can you represent this information
that you're finding?
The interpretations that you're
making, in different ways?
We had them exploring how
to use different visual mapping
tools, including MapStory.
And here you see a nice little
Tweet representing the efforts
that they made to map the history
of alley communities in Washington,
D.C. And the result was
that they got to present,
they were the opening presentation
at the D.C. Historical
Studies Conference.
They shared their process
as high school students
engaging in this kind of work.
And we saw, throughout
that spread of time,
that if you gave these
students the opportunity,
whether in the classroom or in the
archive, that they would be excited.
That they were capable and that
the contribute to the construction
of our understanding of our past.
>> Patrick Cronin: But we
kept running into limitations.
Those conventional
structural limitations.
May they be a bell schedule, or
just a constraint of the classroom.
They could be a scheduling a field
trip, getting permission forms.
All of these, there's
many, many more.
I'm sure many of you have
actually encountered some of these.
So, we started to think, okay,
what's happening elsewhere
where they've done away with or
ameliorated some of these concerns?
And the only thing we
could find is in STEM.
So, this is a photograph
of a STEM lab that is
in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
It's called NuVu.
It was started by an MIT
architectural design PhD student.
And the general model
is the kids are pulled
from their traditional high school
and they work here,
full time, as a student.
And they're engaged in
some really great work.
We went from that concept and said,
how can we start a program that is
without these limitations?
Though, naturally, we
went to the summer.
And our first project was uncovering
the 1968 riots in Washington,
D.C. And it was at the Washington,
D.C. public library special
collections, funded by them.
Here's a picture that is in
the lab of the humanities.
Right. It wasn't artificial,
like that studio you
saw for STEM in NuVu.
It was a common location.
This is, well, the former
Kipling area library
in the Carnegie Building, just up
the road, soon to be an Apple store.
We took students to those places
where overhead is already
taken care of.
Right. Galleries, libraries,
archives, and museums.
Most of which are free
to the public.
And they're welcoming
us with open arms.
Please bring students.
Very glamorous work.
Students wearing white gloves.
Right. This is our
little hub for the summer,
sixty-hour program, two years ago.
Students collaborating
on independent research.
Then, working together on a formal
project, a product, if you will.
We brought in outside experts.
Here, leaning over the
computer and leaning
over a student is a man named
Brian Kraft [assumed spelling].
He's involved, currently, in a
ten-year project to map, digitally,
every building in Washington,
D.C. To call him an expert
is an understatement.
He's leaning over a student who's
working with some RTIS maps.
In fact, it's a map he created.
So, we though actually
we'd bring him out.
At this time, Brian was, this
is, for lack of a better word,
student Brian or little Brian.
Was 14 at the time.
Also, the minimum age that
a researcher can get a card
at the National Archives.
And Brian, why don't
you come on out?
Brian is currently.
[ Applause ]
He's currently a rising junior at
School Without Walls in Washington,
D.C. But he's also one of
15 students in the city
who was just accepted to George
Washington University's early
college program.
[ Applause ]
We thought we'd have Brian
give us his perspective on.
We'll show you some visuals
as we've sort of been doing.
And he'll maybe tell you
a little bit more detail,
what he's worked on that's visible.
>> Brian Kraft: Okay.
So, yeah, that's Brian Kraft.
So, on my lap is a D.C.
report, government report
on the riots and the damage.
So, if you see, it's
this like street images,
like on each block of the damage.
So, basically, what I'm trying
to do is replicate that image
or those images, and so,
sorry, if I'm rambling.
But in this book, there's this
whole like a fold-out page
of like a hand-drawn damage map
of the entire Seventh Street
and 14th Street during the riots.
So, what I'm trying to do is
basically draw out each block,
each building, color it in.
If it's like damaged,
how damaged it is.
If it's salvageable
or unsalvageable.
And replicate it, digitally.
And basically, at this stage,
I was really, you know,
immersed in my work, So,
when he came, I was like,
I don't really need his help, but.
But you know, I still, you know, was
polite, you know, I took his tips.
Like, you know.
But I didn't, I wasn't, so.
But still, you know, it
was a valuable experience.
And that actually turned
into a internship offer
at his engineering firm, GMT.
So, that was cool.
I didn't get to do it.
I didn't get security clearance,
because they're not going to let,
you know, a 14-year-old touch
multimillion dollar documents.
So, I couldn't do that.
But still, good experience.
So, this is the beginning stage of.
So, this is from the
archive, National Archive.
So, we had, I think,
two, three hours.
So, this is basically our only
time to gather original documents.
And so, that's me,
holding that camera,
and that's one of my
partners, James.
So, basically, what we did for two
hours straight, I held the camera.
He flipped the page.
I took the picture.
Flip it. I took the picture.
Flip it. And that was, I
don't know, 30 minutes.
Then, I took a break for my neck.
And I went back at it.
So, we were doing that
for two hours, straight.
So, once we got all the information,
I shared the pictures
with my other partners.
And we had to put it
in this spreadsheet.
So, it's basically 30
columns, horizontally.
Different information, like
the percentage of damage,
how much the damage cost,
the owner of the building.
If it's repairable, what type of
damage; glass, water, fire damage.
And it's about like 90
people in that spreadsheet.
And then, I had to import that
spreadsheet into this map.
So, these little black dots,
those are each of the 90 people
that we collected the reports on.
And if you would click, if
you were to click on it,
you'd see their name, their
age, the building that they own,
the address, what type of damage.
So, there's that.
And then, the red, yellow,
and orange spots you can see
here, is the extent of damage.
That was the hand-drawn
map I was talking about.
I literally had to take a mouse and
draw the rectangle, draw the square,
and then color it in for, I don't
know, about 11 street's worth.
From L to Q, or S,
I don't even know.
But yeah, I had to do that.
And then, if you can barely
see these little plus marks,
those are the images of each block.
So, you are able to get like digital
visual, then an actual visual.
And then, if you click on it,
like the individual details
about the specific building.
>> Patrick Cronin:
Unbelievable work that Brian did.
And we've decided we
would do another project,
the very next summer.
And sure enough, I got an email
from Brian, ''Hey, can I help
and do a different
project?'' I said, ''Well,
you just continue work on the riots.
You don't need me.
What am I going to do for you?
Just work on the riots.
Finish'', you know, ''Go
finish your map.'' He said,
''No, I want to do something.
I want to do your new topic,
''Downtime and Debauchery
in Civil War Washington''.'' We
looked at brothels in the city.
The goal of this project was
to take it to the next level.
We thought Brian was
doing amazing work,
but how do we know where the bar is?
And so, we looked at
existing projects.
This is from Ken Winkle
at University Nebraska,
''Civil War Washington''.
And on this map, there's
a missing layer.
And the layer is brothels
during the Civil War.
So, Brian made the layer.
And it started to get the
attention of the National Archives.
And in fact, Brian was one
of a few high schoolers
to do the first digitization
that exists
in the National Archives catalog.
>> Thomas Neville: So, one more
project we'd like to highlight,
I think, brings in another aspect of
where we think the potential can be
for students working
with collections.
As a teacher at the American School
of Paris, I started a project
and partnership with the local World
War One cemetery, that's managed
by the American Battle
Monuments Commission.
And meeting with the
supervisors there, they said,
''We have all these
soldiers buried here.
And for most of them, we don't
know anything beyond what's
on the grave stone.''
And as a teacher,
that was the perfect problem
statement to start with,
in getting the students engaged.
So, I had my, go back real quick.
Thanks. Eighth graders in
Paris, partner with middle
and high schoolers from Lopez
Island, Washington State,
to research the 29 Washingtonians
buried in this cemetery.
And here's a student who's starting
with the little bit
of data that she has.
And just a glimpse into
this remote collaboration.
These students, nine hours apart,
working together using collections
in their respective countries to try
to collaborate and
tell these stories.
And this is an example.
This is Raymond Bennett.
He died on the first day of
the Battle of Chateau-Thierry.
And this is a mix of documents that
were both digitized and available
in certain databases,
like Chronicling America.
But also, archives and
materials that weren't digitized.
And these students, these
eighth graders learned how
to identify relevant archives,
write them very polite emails.
And ask them if they had
any relevant documents
and if they could digitize
them and email them to Paris.
And they did.
And now, they've aggregated
their work on an app
that you can download, right now,
for free, on the Apple store.
And you can go to the cemetery
and whatever they have found
about these soldiers is pinned
to the location of their grave.
And you can stand there at the
grave and learn about somebody who,
just four months ago,
we knew nothing about.
And we were joined in
less than three months
by an independent researcher
in Pennsylvania,
who offered her own research about
Jewish soldiers from that state.
Independent researcher from
West Virginia, who has confirmed
that he convinced the Undergraduate
Public History Department,
University of West Virginia,
to join in, in the fall.
A family from Illinois,
whose ancestor is buried
in the [inaudible]
cemetery that we studied.
She shared all of her documents
and let us digitize
them, for the first time.
They'd been kept in a cigar box.
And a school in New York
City, you might have heard of,
called Stuyvesant, and
their students jumped in.
And offered more than I
could handle at the time.
And now, you can go, as
these students are doing,
and learn about the
research of others, for free.
Stuff that was never available
before, on a free app.
And we're hoping to get more and
more involvement on this project
and projects like this, that
connect collections across space.
And get students engaged in
processes that develop real skills.
>> Patrick Cronin: Like to
reemphasize that this was Tom's work
with middle school students.
Something to think about.
Maybe, we could trickle up.
[ Laughter ]
This is a little excerpt from
an article written last year.
And Brian was interviewed
for the article.
[ Laughter ]
The line after, we don't have
it, was high praise, indeed.
But that's okay.
We want to come back to Brian,
here, and simply ask him sort
of off the cuff, he's
asking for more time.
The middle schoolers asked, well,
if you had one thing,
what could you do?
Well, we need more time.
We just need more time.
What would you have
done with more time?
>> Brian Kraft: Yeah.
So, the map, that was
Seventh Street.
But another major street during
the riots was 14th Street.
And I wasn't really
able to get to that.
So, if I had more time, I probably
would have done 14th Street.
And then, also, probably would
have gone back to archives,
take more pictures,
get more information.
Probably have more individuals in
the spreadsheet and import that.
But yeah, that's basically
what that was about.
And I think, you know,
archives learning is just
so much more valuable.
No offense, but more valuable
than textbook learning.
Because, you know, you're
experiencing information first-hand,
primary source, you know, usually
superior to secondary sources.
And you can reach your own
conclusions and remember,
and you retain more information,
once you reach your
own conclusion based
on the information
that's given to you.
So, I just think archival
learning is much more,
you know, viable than textbook.
>> Patrick Cronin: And we had
the final challenge, then.
What if students like Brian
had an entire semester?
But your gut reaction is, yeah but.
What if we rethink that?
I'll ask, again.
What if students like Brian
had an entire semester?
Yes and.
>> Thomas Neville: I would just
add that each of the projects
that we've shown you along the way,
we've been met with ''yeah buts''.
And Patrick and I, sort
of our protocol is we call
each other out on that.
And we've been very adamant about
saying, ''Give me a yes and.'' So,
we're asking you to
think about that.
And you can share that conversation
as the lovely deep voice has
been saying on social media.
But we just, don't
yeah but us, right now.
If that was possible, yes and.
Thank you, very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Speaker One: This
has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.